[Music]
as the covet 19 vaccine rollout ramps up
around the globe johnson johnson reports
its one-shot candidate
isn't as effective against the disease
as its two-shot counterparts
from pfizer and moderna but with the
options growing and covet variants to
consider what should people watch for
will it even be a patient's choice what
vaccine they receive
let's ask fox news medical contributor
dr nicole sapphire doctor thanks for
joining us as always so
first if you wouldn't mind speaking to
the efficacy of the johnson johnson
vaccine and then
along with that of course goes the big
question which people always ask is
which one should i get do i have a
choice and how does this all play out
well there's a lot of questions going on
with the the vaccines and the
circulating variants jedidiah but i
think it's really important to talk
about the variants before we get into
vaccine efficacy so we viruses mutate
naturally and actually it's completely
dependent on human behavior the higher
the viral transmission in the community
the more chance it has to mutate which
is why we have so many variants now
circulating the
globe many of these variants are showing
to be more contagious
and also being able to carry a higher
viral load in people which can lead to
overwhelmed hospital systems
has also increased disease severity now
when you take that and you look at the
efficacy trials coming out of these
vaccines
from pfizer and modernity had the
incredible over 90 percent
efficacy during their late stage trials
and now johnson johnson has come out
saying
their single dose shot has had a 66
efficacy
however we can't compare these apples to
apples jetta diet and that's because
these vaccine trials were done at
different times
when madeiran and pfizer underwent their
clinical trials they had
far fewer variants circulating as
opposed to johnson johnson
novovacs and even the later stage
astrazeneca trials
so that may explain why they have a
lower efficacy because even pfizer and
moderna are saying some of
these variants are not responding as
well to their vaccines
the great news though out of johnson
johnson not only is it a single doe shot
easier to transport and
administer however they did show that
there is a hundred percent efficacy in
preventing severe disease
after about a month and a half that's
big news
and so we have to keep things in context
we don't know what the current efficacy
of pfizer and modern are with in large
scale with these current variants so
they're all going to probably be
similar any vaccine you can get your
hands on at this point is the one you
should be getting
so there's a lot of concern about these
different strains we keep seeing in the
news there's this new one from
south africa that is concerning some
what do you know about it so far
so b1352 by 352 the south african strain
is
has a similar mutation to one that's
also being followed out of brazil which
is called p1
these are the variants that we're really
interested in there's many variants of
concern circulating right now there's
the uk one there's one a couple actually
in california
but those seem to just be a bit more
highly transmissible and the vaccines
tend to seem to be conferring immunity
to them as well as previous infection
the south african strain the brazilian
strain as of now
we're showing some some lab data as also
clinical trial data that the vaccines
and even
previous infections may not be giving
immunity
to these new variants um the novovax
trial
um interestingly showed that people that
were getting
coven 19 again many of you actually had
had a prior infection with the south
that with um the proceedings i hate to
interrupt you unfortunately we're going
to have causing reinforcement
for today i appreciate it but we'll have
you we're going to have you back to
expand on this okay
no worries we'll be right back with more
fox and friends on the other side